hier matin jean marie bigard était
interviewé dans la matinale de bfm
pourrait venir sur sa relation avec le
président de la république emmanuel
macron et lors de cette interview il a
balancé ce qu'on appelle une bomba est
oui le journaliste a demandé à jean
marie bigard c'est une candidature à la
présidentielle de 2000 22 pourrait
l'intéresser
et l'humoriste a expliqué qu'il pourrait
être tenté par l'aventuré
depuis tout le monde s'agite de cette
déclaration ça fait la une des chaînes
infos et des jt mais ce que les médias
en font trop
moi je vous raconter une petite anecdote
aussi dans un instant parce que c'est
vrai que tout le monde m'appelle parce
que vous allez voir ils ont vu que
hanouna 2022 étaient déposées j'ai eu 50
appelle aujourd'hui concernant cette
affaire je vous en parle dans un instant
rien c'est cette semaine en direct sur
bfm tv que l'humoriste jean marie bigard
a répondu à une question du journaliste
de la chaîne info sur ses envies de
s'engager en politique après son coup de
gueule remarqué sur la réouverture des
bars et l'appel reçu du président macron
une interview en duplex où il a révélé
s'intéresser à l'élection présidentielle
ça pourrait m'intéresser si je sentais
l'utilité d'avoir quelqu'un de sincère
qui représente réellement le poc doux de
suite c'est le buzz la nouvelle fait la
une de l'actualité occupe tous les
médias aient envahi les réseaux sociaux
sur les chaînes d'info en continu les
bandeaux se succèdent les duplex
également selon patrick sébastien qui a
transmis le numéro de téléphone de jean
marie bigard président macron le
président ne serait pas très content de
cette récupération de la part de
l'humoriste je te cache pas que je crois
que le président est quand même assez
fâché le président rappelait par
gentille âge pour lui de le soutenir lui
dire que la liberté d'expression est né
et il se retrouve à dire macron
m'appeler comme pour avoir deux pour
avoir mon avis et il se nomme rashad su
la faire devient nationale et les
journalistes le compare déjà à coluche
en 1981 sauf que voilà officiellement
jean marie bigard n'a lancé aucune
campagne
alors jean marie bigard pense à l'elysée
les médias en font-ils 3 justement parce
qu'après ça sachez que j'étais en boucle
par tous france 2 bfm ces news lci
tout le monde était en boucle sur cette
déclaration regarder un outil complet
jean marie bigard jean marie bigard jean
marie bigard bigard va-t-il être
candidat en 2020
de jean-marie car nous y moi je suis le
peuple ce qu'on va assister au peuple
contre les vitres jean marie bigard
pourrait se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle en 2021
comme il l'a expliqué sur bfm tv oui
alors le times non je trouve qu'ils en
font pas faisant pas trop puisque
appartements dont jean marie bigard dit
je peux éventuellement y aller
évidemment c'est une information que les
médias doivent traiter
al'inverse par exemple lorsque vous
immédiatement lorsqu'il votre nom avait
été cité vous aviez désamorcée dans la
journée que les médias continuent à en
parler alors que le principal intéressé
10 mais arrêtez c'est absolument pas à
l'ordre du jour là ils en font trop
mais là quand jean marie bigard alimente
lui-même le feu bas et c'est normal
qu'ils en parlent
alors c'est vrai qu'avec six bêtes
ndiaye à la porte parole du gouvernement
qui a réagi aux propos de jean-marie
bigard regardait alain peut botter en
touche je n'ai pas pour habitude de
commenter les échanges du président la
république avec qui que ce soit d'autant
plus lorsqu'il s'agit des changes privé
si tant est qu'ils aient lieu il n'en
demeure pas moins que je m'étonne que
certains commentateurs s'esbaudissent du
fait que le président de la république
puisse avoir des échanges avec untel ou
untel comme s'il y avait des gens avec
qui il était légitime de parler et des
gens avec qui elle n'était pas les
propos de jean-marie bigard depuis c'est
comme entrer pas alors moi je suis
choquée évidemment je trouve que mes 10
ans font du coup trop parce que j'aime
beaucoup jean marie bigard mais la
sincérité c'est pas non plus la seule
compétence qu'il faut près de prison à
un public
il ya quand même une plein de
compétences et les gens y font des
grandes études et cetera alors peut-être
qu'ils sont parfaits déconnecté du
peuple mais que le connecte au peuple
c'est bien avant les compétences près de
président c'est quand même autre chose
et vous jean marie qui reste sas a trait
aux nues maurice il est très drôle c'est
grave c'est un autre débat mais nous ça
veut dire ça ne mérite pas ça ne mérite
pas un tel battage médiatique on dit
mais ça ça mérite un autre filet le
bigaradier réseau peut-être pour partie
fait pas la une des journaux avec sa vie
bien sûr que c'est normal qu'on en parle
autant l'enjeu dans tous les cas les
gens en parlent entre eux donc veulent
en entendre parler
mais on parlera plutôt cool pour jean
même marie bigard qui a vu sa tournée
annulée et qu'avec le corona bas il va
en pâtir comme tout comme tous les
artistes mais ça fait parler de lui et
tant mieux je bernard montiel mais il a
posé quand même deux conditions il a dit
d'abord qu'il voulait voir les réactions
sur les réseaux sociaux
et il a dit que si dépasser plus de 3
millions de connexions favorable à lui
alors peut-être y réfléchir est vraiment
à s'investir mais il a dit également
qu'il serait du côté des gilet jaune
pour pouvoir
cette voix du peuple comme il dit au
près de 10 c'est pas trop ma droite se
présenter c'est kelly et mme valérie qui
ont répondu à la question qui était
posée ce alors est ce que c'est normal
qu'on relève
oui c'est normal qu'on veuille parce que
c'est une information qui est donnée et
chaque média relais donc évidemment un
plus un plus un plus un ça faisait 10 à
l'arrivée ça fait trop ça pas là pour
faire du buzz non plus donc par rapport
à milliards avant c'était bien il savait
cela l'a desservi en fait quand il ya eu
le problème
un du sketch maintenant c'est un côté un
peu plus positif et pour moi c'est que
pour faire du buzz c'est bon parce que
j'allais dire g data corp et correia
rhin parce qu'on en a parlé quand il a
fait pour répondre juste à la question
on en a parlé quand il a fait son bad
buzz avec son sketch là on en parle
aussi
moi j'aimerais pas qu'on en parle
pendant une semaine parce que je vais
reprendre ce qu'avait dit bernard tapie
sur le plateau avec paul amar quand il
était opposé à jean marie le pen et
c'est ce qui fait que moi je ne veux je
ne vais pas dans ces trucs là il lui
avait dit c'est sérieux la politique
c'est sérieux la police et qu'on joue
pas avec la vie des gens alors il est
très bien il est comique et tous ces
parfaits il peut se présenter s'il veut
il à ses 500 signatures
c'est pour sortir un peu de la question
qui se présentent moi personne amusant
c'est de les appliquer on sait pas mais
sont compliquées de dix paires que le
fait d'avoir eu la même histoire ses
jeux mais c'est pas pareil à un coluche
et billard co lucette au dessus quand
même je respecte les gens dire qu'à
l'époque les a pas eues c'est juste de
dire faites faites attention quand il
veut qu'on fait c'est pour l'honneur
vous le verrez chose il a dit c'est
promis lundi s'il est trop 2011 je veux
me faire une raison